hello everyone nice to be here I would
actually prefer to be import or because
I love port wine but it's fine this way
also we're here today and I'm sure I
will try to convince you that you need
to forget about HTTP in when you were
talking about micro services we'll just
we'll chat on slack at the end to see if
I actually managed to go ahead to
convince you to forget about HTTP Oh Who
am I let me see if this works
also I'm a Software Architect at a
company named in dava here in Romania so
here is five o'clock I'm two hours ahead
of you I teach dotnet on Saturdays and I
often write on my blog
Adina codes don't ask me why this domain
but worse I actually write things about
the problems I encountered when writing
code and so on not as often as I would
like to but I do that also I organize a
user group here we moved online and it's
going pretty well I'm trying to reach as
many people as I can in terms of meetups
so online allowed us to do that so a
short agenda for today we're going to
talk about monoliths because we cannot
talk about micro services without going
through monoliths and then we're gonna
see a few options about inter-service
communication going from HTTP calls and
RPC a little G RPC but you already know
that Sean had talked about this and also
about messaging and different types of
messaging so monolith if I would have
been in the room with you guys I would
ask you who here loves monoliths and I
would want a raise of hands and I admit
I love monolith just because the life
was easier than you had a big chunk of
code
you got that from a repo somewhere EFS
or whatever old-style source control
system and then you implemented
something and then if you wanted to
build a system you press built and you
could have gone to take a coffee because
usually the build took very long so that
one it was very self-contained I mean
everything you would you need it was in
there in terms of code and dependencies
it was a single code base so you didn't
need to worry about I don't know
different languages that you do are not
familiar with if the model it was in
c-sharp or java it was about C sharp or
Java and that's it nothing else it was a
single deployable unit I mean in terms
of releases either it worked or it
didn't work but usually the guys from
the ops and the developers that work on
that monolith I had to take extra time
to do the deploys depending on the
business domain so the life for
developers was very easy in terms of
dependencies and breaking stuff it was
very obvious if you broke something
because it was in the same place so in
terms of dependencies you didn't need to
worry about that no getting NuGet
packages from somewhere you just in
references a reference a library that
was already there and your dependency
the class you needed we instantiate it
was there so that single technology
stack made our life easier
in terms of deploys and downtimes well
it wasn't so nice for our businesses or
our clients businesses because down
times were pretty big depending on the
size of that monolith or in the business
down times would take very long of
course there were and there are a lot of
options
behind the load balancers you take one
server down update that and you leave
only one the other server and so on
to minimize the down times but also the
long build times affected the
productivity of developers and that's
why nowadays more and more developers go
and implement micro services as the I
don't know the go-to architectural
approach ok if you start the project
from scratch all the developers go and
said oh we're gonna do marker services
even if it's not needed in every case
continuous delivery well it didn't work
with monolids it was almost zero and
it's hard to test
think about the scenarios where you
deployed that monolith and you
implemented the add-on or breaking
change and then you had to bring over an
army of testers to do small rations to
do every kind of testing that was needed
for the system to be healthy we
delivered in production
ok so issues but our life was pretty
much easy
how about scaling the modern level
yelling the monolith usually implied ok
we have this machine on this size then
we give a bigger machine write more
resources and more CPU but this meant
that we can only scale of course I mean
giving a bigger machine to handle the
load it was necessary I'm not saying
that this is the only way to scale up to
scale a monolith but usually this costs
a lot of money and it not necessarily
implies that if you have twice as bigger
machine it will cost you double the
money
nope we do not have this this relation
it might cost you I don't know triple
the money four times the money for a
double in size machine and I'm not
talking about storage or anything in
terms of resources to handle that load
another thing that wasn't so nice with
the monolith is that well if I don't
know there were parts of the application
that didn't need scaling I mean
functionalities or certain areas that
weren't used that much me you had no
other option than to scale that also so
in terms of costs for the business it
wasn't so let's say not nice okay for
example if the login functionality
wasn't that that used right why scale
that I mean if you have an ID you know a
power intensive or a search of some kind
in your in your app that needs extra
power then you can scale that also the
problem is in monolids
you cannot do that okay so then we think
away with the IT evolving and the demand
of load increasing we thought hey let's
play this monolith so you started to
read about many different design and
micro services and different types of
architecture and instead okay I'm gonna
do micro services and this micro
services basically were carved a carved
out of the monolith what it is it's a
smaller part of monolith it's not a
monolith has its own database and it's
easy to deploy and more than that it's
supposed to be standalone
because stand alone allows you to
maintain it more easier only that it's
not necessarily true right because if
you split your big ball of mud into
smaller pieces
it might give you I don't know more
headaches
why because introduces complexity and
sometimes you have cascading effects in
case of failure and you need to keep an
eye of Airy close eye on this micro
services you need to monitor them you
need to introduce extra layers of
keeping an eye on these like I don't
know extra monitoring tools and there's
words and so on more ops people right so
now you so realize that your
services architecture that should be
independent and should allow to have
independent units we'll give you
something like this like you so realize
you need data from some other service
and your go-to option to fix that days
is transferred that in the case of
Monell it was easy
it wasn't desert in the same boundary
now you need to communicate to other
services somehow and usually that
communication is done to http clients
right server to server you do a call and
then you realize that you need more and
more data from other sides and you need
more data and more data and you get
something like this you need to make
your small and independent units
communicate somehow and to go to option
when you first start with micro services
is HTTP request no matter what kind of
HTTP that is the go-to option I did it
myself
so you soon end up with something like
this right it's a modern architecture
you have independent units that are
scalable with their own database REST
API eyes and so on you end with some and
I put something like that or maybe with
something like that so you so realize
that your monolithic alive as a
developer was very nice and cozy and you
have no problems you didn't have the
same problems as you have now but if you
think and look around in the industry
you see that Amazon for example makes
150 API calls to build a page it's a lot
for a single trait right so imagine how
many micro services they have and you
look at last six and they have like five
billions of API calls per days and from
these 97.7 are internal so it's not like
a client app calling server side up it's
like interest
communication and then you think okay
these guys can do it I can do it also I
mean I don't have such a big app I do
not have such chip mungus infrastructure
I should be able to do it and then you
realize your options and the go to
options as I already mentioned is make
an HTTP call it is very easy it's
synchronous we all are familiar with
HTTP code we have an HTTP request right
Heather's body HTTP verb and so on we
pretend that we have REST API eyes with
all everything in there and we do these
calls but these calls are api to api
like service to service and what happens
is your Rico's request goes out it's
processed by the other side and then you
get the response back it's very easy and
we all are familiar with this and we are
happy but what happens if your request
is processed from the other side and
something happens over the network and
you do not get the response back of
course you're very sad but how do you
handle that because if you think of this
API to EPA called needs to be monitored
right because you might not even know
that a request has been made first you
do login tracing you log everything
there you throw exceptions you I don't
know a dirty your code with every kind
of I don't know try caches and
monitoring stuff just to present this
kind of issues happening but the idea is
that you cannot prevent them because for
example if when you should request and
the other side doesn't receive the
request how do you tell that the request
has taken place or that has taken place
why the other and received right so then
I mean I don't know I don't want to get
into details but is simple right you
issue requests
the other side is down what happens well
we are you either wait and log and you
retry and you need to implement retry
mechanism yourself and the best scenario
you will get a timeout if the other side
it's not down in together 500 and lock
that and so on right and then he said
okay HTTP calls simple let improve a bit
and then you said hmm maybe it's
perfectly fine to use this I mean as the
first step working with micro services
is just fine but how about timeouts how
long do you wait for the other side to
respond how do you decide that okay
after 30 seconds I will issue a timeout
my calling party or how do i implement a
retry about availability if the other
side is down how do what do I do
I really should request the other part
it will still be down right how about
reliability if the network has an issue
okay it's inside my on premise
infrastructure or in cloud and so on but
the infrastructure is not reliable I
mean once you get a request over the
network you need to assume that is not
reliable you cannot pretend that
everything will work yes it works on my
machine in your machine but not
necessarily in the production
environment
how about retries I mean we're trying
for how long how many times in what time
span right and the deal is that in HTTP
clients that we do ourselves no matter
the language we do not have this
returning out of the box we need to
implement the retrying everything by
ourselves of course there is Paulie or
similar libraries that Allah was to
implement retries policies but pretty
much we need to do manual work prevent
this but
how about coupling I mean how do you
distribute these HTTP clients there is a
service PE and you said you have micro
services that's independent units and so
on but you need somehow to make the the
parties aware of the interface
definition language okay what is the
answer that the other part can't
understand and what is the response that
the first part you can understand right
so we end up doing that alone now get
packages I come from dotnet world and
the Nugget packages are you go to option
and I've seen projects where we had a
nose
lots of Nugget packages that contained
not only the HT client and the interface
is that we need but also creating hard
business logic for those crimes and it
was a mess and yet
okay so let's be aware of these and then
if we say okay we're fine we implemented
retry policies okay we're fine with
coupling the package and code distribute
distributions and so on let's increase
the throughput and wanting to increase
the throughput you pretty much go to
async there are so many parodies
nowadays that allow you to work with
icing if you come from a dotnet word
that is the sink weight that makes it
very easier for us to work with parallel
right and then you said hmm
I have an idea I'm gonna use it a thing
because I'm gonna get rid of all these
problems it will solve pretty much all
the problems I have from using HTTP and
I'm not waiting for a response to to
come back but is it an HTTP protocol
it's a transport right so saying that
it's perfectly fine to use async calls
because it gives you the impression that
it distributes the load and you increase
the throughput it doesn't work because
you'll have the same exact issues but
not only that your requests will request
the responses will
often come back out of order and nope
you cannot serve more requests is the
appearance of it and you can serve the
requests faster because you're not
blocking something and you're not wait
waiting for a response you have the
promise that the response will come back
but what if that Rico's require a
response hasn't come back how do you
will know what requests you issued in
the first and E you can log but why log
everything I mean understand doing
defensive programming but not at that
level so what happens here
if the words I'm I'm pushing an eye that
is increased by one and under time span
of 20 seconds you assert an API right so
pretty much what I want to see here is
to measure how many requests I can post
in 20 seconds timespan and it says here
I push that number three thousand and
five hundred requests pretty much who
they went right we issued those requests
but what if I told you that the
receiving party was them I'm using I
think I'm using async look at how many
requests
I pushed to the network but where is the
reliability here there is a guarantee
that I received my request and we
understand other side nope
so using async doesn't give you
something extra is more than that it
gives you the impression that you pushed
more requests so you increase the
throughput but you still have the same
problem right so if you go back to HTTP
in general it doesn't matter what
paradigm use it in when programming that
it's sync by nature that's it and not
only that
you make for each HTTP client now the
in.net at least that problem is pretty
much solved but when using an issuing
the new request to an HTTP client you
make a new TCP connection for each
request absolutely and there are no
retries out of the box you add poly you
add everything and there are no delivery
guarantee hey you issued the request on
the site that issues the request
everything is fine ok ask something from
the other side
that's it I'm waiting for a death
promise that the response will come back
and it doesn't come back and location
transparency there is a pretty big issue
here this you need to know exactly where
are you calling you need to know the
domain you need to note maybe the port
assigned to your app why not and if you
are on Paramus
you need to have big lists with all your
apps and when your apps are changing in
terms of domain or environments you need
to be very careful to change in your
documents that you have and to remember
that you need to update your URLs the
new URLs and internal HTTP is very good
for public facing API in terms of client
apps
I don't know mobile apps and so on it's
very good and it's very familiar to
every junior developer if you match them
to them HTTP they will know that they
have a body Heather and so on verbs and
pretty much everything they need get
going and it's easy to debug right but
what happens if a new API comes in into
discussion how about service discovery
let's say you do not have an API
management fancy stuff like in the cloud
your on-premise you will need to
document and to make the other services
aware
that hey there is a new service in the
network that you need to call and you
need to change all the parties involved
if you have one new micro service that
needs to communicate with other three
then you need to inform the other trees
three micro services that hey here's the
new service you need
how about timers we we briefly talked
about this but since the network is not
reliable we need to expect time out and
in timeouts and retries and so on brings
us a lot of let's call it patterns that
and problems that we didn't have before
like we try policies and I will mention
here a few a few patterns like circuit
breaker bohag bulkhead fallback and many
others that we weren't aware before okay
we're gonna implement this retry policy
document everything okay we thank God
there is these libraries that take care
of these kinds of patterns for us but
it's not so easy progressed so we need
to learn something new in terms of
tracing there is there are a few options
you need to trace what request write
HTTP request more than that so for each
request you issue through your api's you
need to have something that will give
you the possibility to see okay I'm in
the service a and I call service B that
service B as a response to my request
needs to call some service old C right
you need to create all these passes to
leave traces be able to debug in a way
or another what happens inside your
system and it's not very easy to do
because you need to add correlation IDs
and to store that those somewhere right
you can add correlation idea to
Heather's or whatever technology stack
you you need but it's still a piece of
work
and microservices promote the glt and
the productivity and there's a team that
isn't independent in their knows the
business does the job delivers there
right but look that it's not so easy
okay so now saying that HTTP okay maybe
it's not such a good options between the
inter-service communication you say oh
recently there is something called G RPC
still uses HTTP but HTTP too
it's very developer friendly and its
high performance does very well to
serial nation and so on
let's go ahead and use it maybe you've
seen Sean presentation but I will go to
this very briefly its contract base you
basically specified what you need there
are no nugget packages or whatever code
references you only reference these
files and since it's you it uses HTTP to
it's inherently faster than previous
HTTP the serialization makes it very
performant because it has a smaller
payload but the deal is that you cannot
like debug this this is binary and you
need special tools for it but it's
available in many language languages
which well it may be beneficial for the
system because maybe you have a
component that is written in go or in
Java that you need to communicate with
right and also it has some code
generation out of the box which is very
nice and as a concept GRP steve relies
on these proto files that have a
specific syntax and this proto files
will stay and will be let's call it
shared in a way but Rob the ICD system
through your api's right so now you have
no code references you have this proto
file that isn't common right so how it
looks
it's basically like this it's you define
this service you have here like service
called phoebo it's an RPC has a name has
parameter and returns a type of data and
then you go there and specify the tapes
types of data that are used by our
service and pretty much this is it
you have the specification interface
definition language and you're good to
go using command-line tools and so on it
will generate code for you in no matter
what language do you need right so G RPC
might be a good candidate right but we
as a developer and I a new thing we kind
of need to think of some non-functional
requirements we call them any farce in
architecture world what is a
non-functional requirement it's pretty
much something that cannot be attested
by a manual tester to validate in terms
of functionality but it really helps the
business in terms of how the application
of the system in itself should behave we
need to think about availability right
we need to see if our services are up we
need to monitor that and we need to say
hey those nines with 999 point many
nines availability right oh it's related
to that we need to see how fault
tolerant our is our system we need to
think about latency and throughput of
the system and of course reliability
some of these are in a way
generating the others and are very
closely related to each other
observability how do you observe a
system that is made of so many pieces
and in itself each piece needs to be
available needs to have a high enough
support and needs to be fault tolerant
because if you take into account the
latency
then your system might be he'll behave
well or not so well in different
circumstances and also resilience right
so if we think about micro-services and
all these things that should be in my
opinion might not be a popular opinion
should be like common sense from for
every developer if your client or the
business doesn't care about these you as
a developer should care about this
because I know it's very easy to say in
front of your computer and write call
deliver functionality you see
immediately the response of what you are
doing but these things are very
important for certain domains for
certain businesses right for example
think about I don't know Black Friday or
special promotion for a business that is
online like I don't Amazon right they
need to process the requests fast as
fast as they can to take the clients
money and also needs to be available so
that to be able to take the clients
money right needs to be reliable if we
think like okay maybe not to take the
clients money twice or so on right I
need to be observable they need to have
some ops guys to monitor the system the
in case of an extreme loading they need
to scale very fast and if that load
decreases they need to decrease to let's
say reduce their costs with the
infrastructure and so on right now we
need to take into account all these
things when designing and implementing
something and if we think about marker
services there is the coupling court
right beforehand when we talked about
all object-oriented programming and so
on we said okay coupling high cohesion
location and so on then when we grow
when you think about systems in their
entirety we need to think about logical
coupling of the components in the
systems and
temporal coupling and what HTTP pretty
much does is to enforce a coupling
temporal because we need both systems to
be up if those system needs to
communicate with each other logical
coupling just because we need to share
some way the interface definition
language so both parties know what to
expect from each other right so even in
micro-services if we are using HTTP
clients we have these op links that
supposedly micro service is solve but we
go back to the monolith and introduce
nugget packages and code sharing and so
on and we kind of defeat the purpose
okay moving on HTTP it is done it's not
so good but it's the first step when you
do micro services the idea is it's with
micro services if you first do HTTP
requests between between them then we
need to take a step back and say hey
what other options do I have
and then you have G RPC and after a
while same he lets evolve our
architecture and move on
and moving on means maybe at first doing
remote procedure calls a message broker
and how this is looking like RPC in
terms of message broker it's kind of API
called
where indeed we try systems together but
we preserve their encapsulation and we
make some external system calls look
local and there are no direct
codependency
oh how it's done basically we have a two
systems that write communicate with each
other so a request goes but it goes
through a queue not directly to a
service and from that queue it's picked
up by let's call it handler service V
right and the service B processes the
requests get the answer back to the
first service for the thank you it's
replied right let me show you something
so I have here an RPC server RPC service
is not exactly correct instead I am
using
rabbitmq as a message broker but let me
show you something
so in here I have this server I hope
it's big enough in terms of font so it's
the server it's a console app I will
show you that also that awaits request
and in the other side I will have a
client that issues requests right so the
left-hand side wait and the other side
ask something and what s is same an i
right
ok so it's a request response but
through a queue let me show how this
queue looks this is rabbitmq the
interface is very nice and you have here
the queues and when you start doing this
ok so the client will send an eye that's
it an eye that is increased by 1 you see
that this queue has incoming stuff right
and this also but the server doesn't
process anything so let's see this is
request reply and the request reply
means that it's not a sink I mean you
issue requests you wait for the response
and that's it the response may not come
back but the issue is that the request
you you you're giving there the through
the queue won't be lost anymore you will
know that the request was there so just
the sec
what do you gain versus HTTP right
adding a queue you don't lose the
requests because the requests will stay
in that queue until some some something
a consumer will be able to pick those
and process them if it's needed you can
add more instances of consumers process
the requests is like adding more more
servers to be able to handle the load
and you can apparently spread the load
and yes you can process more requests
because it's done through a different
protocol than HTTP called AMQP and we'll
talk about at the end but issue is it
still sink and you need to match the
request with the response like in terms
of HTTP so pretty much you didn't solve
anything but you solve the let's call it
real life the temporal coupling issue
because if the processing party is
someone said that you lose the ability
yeah you kind of but I'm sure I'm gonna
show you it's the code is very easy so
messaging what's a message right it's
like an envelope with the body at the
header so if a request has headers and a
body and a verb translating that to the
message you will have the same body in
the body of the message and the Heather
like dictionary true this envelope
it's the headers in a message is no
matter what message broker you are using
is the same it's a dictionary where you
can add whatever you want in there so
messaging as a concept as a whole will
give you a loosely coupled the
integration you won't have like nugget
packages flying around to reference in
different systems and it doesn't require
both system to be up more than that he
can give you a lot of flexibility in
terms of what you can do with the
messages for example you can create
something like pipelines made of from
these cubes called the enrichers right -
I don't know - add something
threat to your messages and then you're
gonna send that message to a different
queue to be picked up by consumers and
so on
but if you heard about cap tail theorem
you cannot have three three things at
the same time you can have only two and
messaging system straight consistency or
availability but the fact that you are
not losing messages increased is your
real I built right everything that goes
through your system is there somewhere
but is there and not only that is there
you can replay that if there have they
have this concept of dead letter Q where
some messages that can't be processed go
there and you can see them see those
there you can pick up from there and so
on you can create rules depending on the
message brokers or you are using and so
on but compared to HTTP you have a
reliable system in a way right but you
want to lose requests or messages
because those messages go through
something work you usually and stay
there
even if the other party is down what
will happen is when the other party will
come back up where those messages will
be processed okay I have another small
demo let me close this out okay RPC
close
just a sec okay
so I have here something that is a
simply sends messages like the same I in
a time span and you'll see that not only
the throughput is way higher than we've
seen before
they've 70,000 and so on and time is
passing and this is going is going there
so I'm mimicking the fact that I'm
issuing requests or creating messages
right
the fact is nothing consumes them there
isn't the receiving party is not up
right so pretty big amount of messages
process and if I'm looking through the
rabbitmq look let me just zoom a bit I
have this cold pump you're very inspired
where I have this amount of messages and
are there because nothing consumed them
nothing received there also someone
mentioned in the chat that I can also
send in the RabbitMQ in the interface
yes you can also do that so not only
that you have a visibility in terms of
how many messages went through your
queue and so on how many are ready how
many are published the total and so on
you can also get messages from there
VCC is such a big payload because it's
only an int 0 1 2 or 3 and so on
increasing I in that 20 seconds time
spent but the messages are here so
whenever the other system will be back
up because now is down will pick up the
messages and it will process it process
those right so reliability okay so let's
see further what we have a think
distributed system supposed supposed to
be async because we want the best out of
those illa teas so to do this at first
you can do something like this you issue
a request to a cube
other requests rikuo or as many requests
as you can and there will be a handler
that will pick up these requests or
messages and will respond in another
queue and in the other hand there will
be something picking them up right so
picking them up what you'll need to do
is to see what you sent in these
messages right and you say oh how am i
how much messages how many messages I'm
sending 100,000 and something compared
to 1,000 or three hundreds when using
HTTP very cool but what happens if you
add the database you need to send
something to process something and then
save that's something in a database well
then you have a different set of
problems because we all know that the
database is let's say limited you can
indeed process more requests are using
async you try to get through your system
as many requests as you can or messages
right you can process them faster
because the protocol is different in
this case you do not lose them so you
increase the reliability but in some
cases you may move your problem some
other sides of the system and in this
case is database because and also
eventual consistency remains or becomes
the problem depending on how you design
your system what is the solution because
we know the connection pool is cars we
have I don't like 100 1000 or whatever
but if the throughput is so much bigger
than your connection pool you'll have
issues and how you can solve this is by
batch processing the messages or I don't
know maybe we use the semaphore to
process the meme in batches or
add more consumers but adding more
consumers for the same queue will end
you up in the same place right because
you're still gonna have 100 connections
to the database and you have like three
consumers consuming five messages per
second or so on and maybe the numbers
don't add up
right so why use a messaging system with
micro-services and why switch from the
HTTP to this messaging stuff because as
we see it solves some issues but the
introduces on others so for agility I
would say because you have faster
development once you get a grasp of it
there is no integration process there
are no not yet packages or whatever
packages to share in there you depend
only on a response or or not this design
of a system that will give you the
maximum benefits themes will still have
full ownership of understanding of the
code base but there is the slides let
learning curve when moving from the HTTP
to my ear to my two messaging because
you do not have this part in requesting
something waiting for response or
debugging at the breakpoint it was
happening and so on and usually when
you're on your local development machine
everything works smooth but you realize
soon that well if you need the messages
to be in order and sometimes there
aren't in order and so on you'll be in
you lose the debug enos of the of the
entire system but that can also be
solved you need to trace you traced also
in HTTP you can switch technologies if
needed so having this this broker and
these queues will allow you to switch
microservices technologies maybe you
should see that i'll go or python is
suitable enough tech or language for a
specific part of your system
then you can switch it maybe you find
that dotnet is not so good in nano
parsing messages or whatever or Java
isn't or Java is better why not and then
you can switch okay I'm gonna I'm
deciding that starting tomorrow that
part of the system will be written in a
different language so you can go ahead
assign that small part of the system
what specific team I think we will see
the job done and then you will need to
do just the deploy and that's it you can
have things working in there so not only
agility but you'll have better
scalability and you have increased
throughput with micro services right
because from a small machine you go to a
bigger machine and you could scale up
but now not only you can scale up you
can scale out so the two ways of scaling
by adding more machines or adding on
certain machine Moore's the processing
power or maybe more memory and also why
not
scaling up you can do all these things
by having marker services and a
messaging system in here because it will
give you back something that HTTP didn't
give you in the first place and also you
will have increased throughput I mean
you saw the difference we here I had an
old machine that the difference was this
but in the current machine I had one
thousand and something messages process
which is it's a lot right think of I
don't know IOC a sensor data that comes
in your system and needs to be processed
and so on I mean you need to be fast
there to process as much as you can you
have an increase to the messaging will
give you that also elasticity you can
scale down a reduced cost you can spin
another instance that will consume your
app to process faster then you can kill
one of those consumers as soon as your
load period ends up not only that but it
will give you a lot of ILIT ease
reliability that
way better than in HTTP like stability
reliability twice increased throughput
elasticity and pretty much a lot of
elytis performance and filter tolerance
out-of-the-box what tools framers and
options do you have
there are a lot other they call them
buses or message brokers or simply
messaging systems they pretty much all
relies on we rely on cues of some kind
with different level of abstraction and
service pass now it's very cool and it's
not only very cool they have a free
course available if you look on their
site on distributed systems whatever
system you will see here like MQM Q with
Q or something it's the same relies on
Q's right kafka 0 and Q and many more in
case of these systems the level of
abstraction is more or less depending on
it and the protocol they use is maybe
HTTP on a forum or others but in this
case I choose random cube because is the
first one I got the chance to work with
and more than that if we look at the
types of these systems we can look at
simply queues that will all familiar
with actor model there was a talk today
about actor models akkad net and so on
and message brokers what's the cue
simply the sender sent something through
a queue or receivers pulls from that
queue and it's very useful for point
upon point communication messages are
ordered in timestamp so is the most
basic queuing system that messaging
system that you can you can get its pull
mode so the receiver will take things
from there right and as on sqs and many
others you you can also do it yourself
but you will lose the the
fostering options that are offered out
of the box and the dead-letter queues
and so on of these systems after model
early on a cadet net are born from
reactive programming I wouldn't get into
details here because there was a talk
today it have they have at most once
delivery and usually run on top of other
systems if they are born in a way from
the reactive manifesto because the
system this needs to be responsive
enough resilient and message drivel and
elastic because nowadays let's take the
modern web right if we go to a website
and then we click a button and nothing
happens where we wait and we see the
spinner in the air we turned to what
with is this crappy website I'm gonna
look some other website right so the
more the data is increasing so the
storage is very cheap the amount of data
to transfer into our system is very big
so we need to process data faster and to
respond faster to adapt to the needs of
the modern web right by the way this
reactive manifesto as an FYI was first
mentioned in 73 and 2009 it was the
first Java version but well the message
brokers are different species of these
messaging systems there are like a
control tower that control airplanes
that are in the airports and so on what
happens in a message broker they
supervise everything they know how to
handle let's call it who load they know
how to route messaging messages on
different queues depending on some
routing keys for example RabbitMQ does
this they can have one or many consumers
and they can handle connection in these
connections of these consumers
out-of-the-box and very well
and also they have this dead letter Q
concept which means that a message is
that can't be processed or sent there a
certain amount of time that is
configurable and also it's configured
from figure above by some other other
means depending on its system and go to
this letter Q and you won't lose that
message you will find it there like
garbage poison message is also called
the guarantees of these message brokers
are of three sides and they use
different protocols
other examples of message brokers right
Oh Nets RabbitMQ Nets by example it's
used by HTC
HTC demons Ericsson and so on and they
have handle loads big loads very well
about the guarantee of delivering there
are just three of them and each of them
I will just mention briefly exactly what
it means like your request will be
delivered to a cure and consumer exactly
once at least once right and at most
once depending on the types of message
delivery types you need in your system
you might end up in troubles or not but
that deserves a totally different talk
so if the business needs specific and
order messages you need to choose one of
these if the order doesn't matter maybe
you can choose any of these and so on
and another thing not all old message
brokers support all three kinds right
light weights cues are first-in
first-out usually and support this
awesome protocol that I really enjoyed
and pretty much all of them have at
least once delivered mqp I mentioned it
briefly it's a protocol born a long time
ago now has the version of one one zero
it's a let's call it nurtured by the OSS
the
um it has a guarantee message delivery
you have no DNS resolve and no new DCP
connections with each message you pass
through and it has programmatic routing
grid tries are out of the box and also
by hand you can acknowledge or not
acknowledge something a message
processing out of the box right so
compared to HTTP now we have a lot of
things out of the box just by changing
the protocol and how it looks this AMQP
in it took me awhile to find this
picture so it's basically like a channel
right because it has this concept of a
channel and inside the channel you have
back and forth
that's called ways of sending messages
and if you look at this I don't know red
one think of a connection as being the
red rubber stuff and the channels are
the words inside of it I think I did
that you open a connection once and then
you move data to it
right compared to HTTP or for which each
request you need to do another TCP
connection another TCP connection and so
on and that's one of the reasons that
makes em to be very fast another example
I can give you that we use like a ship
service bus that behind-the-scenes uses
queues and so on but we change the
protocol and we ended up like doubling
the throughput in our system just by
changing the protocol so if you you
already using this kind of system look
for mqp
it will pay out so depending on the
broker you have you can have
point-to-point okay so from point A to
point B I need to send the message
something like this based on a routing
key Oh some kind or you can run out or
broadcast Oh
your consumers will get a copy of the
same message
a shirt if you're talking about cloud as
the similar card said but it's called
Asia topics right this topic exchange in
rabbit is called topic because you can
assign a routing key that has a pattern
and depending on the routing here
sending it will end up in a queue or
another queue depending on what you add
in here so starred means that if we have
a word and in front and orange and then
something else it might go in q1 and if
you have lazy dot something then it or
surely end up in the second queue where
we'll be processed by a consumer right
and it's very powerful
think of this scenario about I don't
know sending waltz with a different
severity or your Ops guys some
preferences enterprise integration
patterns we'll have more details and a
lot of details and it's very useful to
read and also designing data intensive
application you might want to have a
look at this it both of these are like
Bibles in terms of not size but in terms
of know-how around micro services and
integrating different different systems
what I want to say is that distributed
systems in their way of being are about
trade-offs and you need to be very
careful about picking what is really
important for your business for your
client and bear in mind that HTTP is not
the only option worse when you first
start with micro services do that it is
the easy way out but then as soon as you
can investigate and move on
evolve your architecture because it will
only make your system better and more
reliable and will add all the LEDs
you're so and many others so remember
that HTTP is not reliable
and you lose requests and you do not
even know that request was made and with
messaging you can process more you have
increased your boot you have reliability
and you won't have that temporal
coupling so I think time's up
thank you for being here it was a
pleasure for me I'm very sorry that I
couldn't have in be in the same room
with you guys you can find me on Twitter
and also you can find me on slack if you
have questions I saw some small the
tooltips popping up but let's meet on on
snack if you have questions thank you
guys enjoyed the race or the rest of
your conference okay thank you very much
thank you
you